hi everyone it's jerry this is video 23
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos
and i'd like to
discuss good bishops
and bad bishops
this is in my opinion
one of the most if not the most
important concepts in the game
if you're excited about learning
uh
tactics one two three move combinations
white to move and win black to move and
win type stuff
you're in the wrong place the focus here
is on strategy
one of the greatest strategic minds the
game has ever seen
mikhail bodwinick he once said chess
mastery
essentially consists
of analyzing chest positions accurately
what i'm looking to do here
through
several examples
is
give you the tools
to
analyze chess positions accurately
to give you the tools to be a better
decision maker when you sit down at the
board
whether it be
in the opening
middle game or end game
this concept this idea here
has an influence on all phases
of the game that's how important i feel
this
topic is
for example in the opening
where should you
deploy your pieces uh more specifically
where should you deploy your bishops
your pawns
what color squares in general
should they be positioned on
the middle game
what minor piece exchanges are you
welcome to which ones are you not
welcome to
the end game
are you playing with the superior minor
piece
are you playing just in general
are you playing
in a good environment
okay are you the side who is struggling
you can't get your pieces to function
properly what's influencing this
okay
those questions and hopefully many more
will
be cleared up
by this videos and you'll have a better
sense of how to answer those questions
now the first example of
many is the one you see here and i would
not at all be surprised if many of you
already formed your own opinion
of this first example those of you who
are thinking
this is ridiculous
i would have to agree with that this is
a ridiculous
first example
an unrealistic
example uh but
nevertheless a good example i would like
to first define what i mean by good
bishops and bad bishops
this guy here on c1 we call him a bad
bishop
why
well
the pawn said so
okay we look to the pawns to determine
which bishops are good or bad okay
white
has
pawns that are fixed
on dark squares
that makes a dark square bishop that
makes white's dark square bishop
the only bishop white has
that makes this bishop bad
okay why well
his value is diminished his mobility
is diminished because the pawns get in
his way
now in this specific example
his mobility is extremely
uh
restricted
he will never
see
a single dark square
on the enemy side of the board okay that
is
this is an extremely
bad bishop or
what uh
i might identify as
a tall pawn okay he's really bad
okay black's bishop on the other hand we
consider this the good bishop
okay why well
notice black has pawns fixed on light
squares
and they do not
restrict
black's bishop okay they do not get in
the way
or limit this bishop in any way
now those of you who have been
connected with me for some time
you know whether you're
listening to me as i play a game blitz
game bullet game slower game like
standard
you have a good sense of how i think in
the terminology that i use
black here has good coordination we
might say
good coordination
between
structure
and
bishop okay another term that i like to
use
is harmony okay
black has
a good
blend
a good mix
good control let's say of both
color complexes notice
the pawns control
the light squares
and the bishop
is just a move away from being able to
control any
of these dark squares
okay
there is a good blend good coordination
black has good harmony
between
structure
and bishop
white
does not
white has good control over the dark
squares
we can say
black excuse me white has good
dark square control
but is weak
on controlling
the light squares right this bishop will
never control
any light squares of course
okay
in this position it is white to move
the bishop plays here to defend the pawn
and i'm just going to play out a couple
more moves after bishop to e7 we can see
now
that uh white is not even
going to be able to defend h4 black will
win this pawn and go on to win the game
this is one of the benefits of having
good harmony between your structure
and your pawns okay you can
target the enemy pawns like this a
couple of are under fire
and white will not be able to attend to
both okay
let's have a look at
an example that's
a little bit more
realistic
here we go
all right so a couple instances here
of fixed pawns and just quickly
identifying
the good bishop or bad bishop in this
position
uh
two pawns here fixed on dark squares
that's the bad bishop
and this guy here
it's white who
has good harmony in this position
pawns fixed on light
and the bishop ties in very well
uh
dark square bishop
this is the good guy on c1
in this position it's white to move just
playing out a couple more moves here
uh or a couple of moves bishop to e3
now observes both
pawns black can now defend
both pawns
and after king 2 e4 we have an
interesting position
black is in
a difficult spot right now
a term that is used to describe
uh black's current position right here
is zuksfang
which is
basically a
position where you don't want it to be
your move
okay
because
any move that black makes here
will give something up whether it be a
square or material in this case it's
going to be
black will give up a square and
ultimately that will lead to the loss of
material
one example of this is well first off if
the bishop makes any move
like here
white can pick up the c pawn
and if black goes here
you could pick up the g pawn
any bishop move and one of these two
pawns will drop any king move
and white will be able to enter with the
king
king here
black king goes to d5 and then picks up
the c pawn
or if he goes here white goes here and
picks up this one
black is in zukswang black is in a
position where
he kind of wants to pass and say you
know what
you make a move white but unfortunately
it's black to move you can't just pass
like this
now
this is not the reason why
you know okay black has a bad bishop in
this position this is not the reason why
playing with a bad bishop
isn't uh a good idea because you're
going to end up in zukswang of course
this could happen but really the big
thing here
the big term to really reflect on
is that when you play with a bad bishop
you are restricted in some way you are
the side who will
uh you know it will be your opponent who
is
uh throwing the punches we're seeing
this in action right here it's white who
has pressure on the black pawns and
black is
just barely trying to hang on and defend
white is the side for choice here white
is really the only side who could try to
win
white has good harmony once more between
structure
and bishop
let's have a look at another example
here we go
team white
so
maybe a bit more of a realistic position
here
white to move if you'd like to pause the
video what move would you play
in this position i'm just going to get
on with it there are a lot of examples
to get through here
white to move what would you
do okay
white to move well actually if it was
black to move
each side would really want to make the
same move in this position whoever is on
move they would like to make the same
move
what is that move exactly a6
this is a winning move
what is white doing well he is fixing
a pawn
on a dark square and he will next look
to
target it how the game may play out
black maybe improves the king
the bishop now eyes up this pawn
a check is thrown in the apon falls
this is now a past pawn the king has to
attend to it
and meanwhile the white king
can scoop up the other pawns
and go on to actually
win this one
now being up two pawns white will go on
to win the big thing to take away from
this one
is
in these
end games
ideally what would you like to have
happen we're working with dark square
bishops it would be a good idea if you
could somehow manage to fix your
opponent's pawns on dark squares so that
you can then
target them
white first plays a6
and then goes after this guy here
okay if you play bishop to d4 this
throws the game away okay white will no
longer be able to win it will result in
a draw black now gets to play a6 and it
may be
the bishop who one day comes around
somehow and puts pressure on the a5 pawn
and it's white who's having to defend
okay
let's go on to
another
example
here we go
so this is similar to
an example i just showed a couple
a couple examples ago here
notice
black has the bad bishop
white has the good bishop
and i just want to show you
that
the bishop
and pawns alone
can
draw this position
it's almost like you don't even need the
king in this position i want to
highlight this idea of harmony and how
the bishop and pawns
work well together and in this
particular case you don't even need the
king's assistance
for example what do we do here well the
pawns are controlling the light
and the bishop is there to control
the dark square
notice this one's covered this one's
covered the king
could never go to these squares because
the pawns are there
and if he ever tries to let's say sneak
over here the bishop can always pivot
on c3 and guard that square
the whole fifth rank
can be in summary under control by just
the pawns and the bishop the king his
assistance is not even needed
bishop to b2 black may try to exchange
bishops
and then you know after a bishop
exchange
black will be able to sneak in and win
but
white simply avoids that exchange he
ducks
and
just playing it out a little bit more
suppose black tries
something else
like king to e5
notice the bishop can return here give a
check
and if the king tries to approach one of
these pawns the bishop will be lost
okay there is simply no good way forward
here the bishop
and pawns alone will be good enough
to restrict the black king from making
progress there is good harmony once more
between white's structure and bishop
let's have a look at another example and
this one
comes from a game i played not too long
ago
pull this one up
this was a
a one minute game so you'll
just have to mind some of the
mistakes that are made along the way but
right out of the opening here i'm
playing as white
as soon as this move is played right
here
what i'm saying to myself is
this is my bad bishop we only have one
case here of fixed pawns the e4 pawn and
e5 pawn are fixed
we can now identify
uh the good bishops and the bad bishops
okay now they're they're going to be
positions where and we're going to see
this there's going to be positions where
you know there's
fixed pawns on both colors
and it's going to be a little bit
trickier to define
which bishops are good or bad in some
cases we might have to just say you know
it's undefined okay we're not going to
be able to
see certain position types
with a great clarity
in this position here we can go ahead
and identify which bishops are good
and bad okay this is from white's
perspective here for looking at the
white bishops first
okay working with many more pieces all
of a sudden i realized but
this guy on e2
that's the bad bishop
the one on c1 that's the good bishop he
ties in well looking at the fixed pawns
he ties in well and there's good harmony
between the dark square bishop and the
pawn on e4
for on a black side
this is the bad bishop
and
this guy here on c8
that's the good bishop
okay he ties in well
with the fixed pawn on e5
let's continue just making some moves
i want to get to
this one position right here after
bishop to e6 one
thing i'm already looking to do is
exchange light square bishops or in
other words
exchange my bad bishop for my opponent's
good bishop that exchange happens
and what i'm trying to do here and i
know it's just a bullet game but i'm
still trying to apply these uh concepts
here this is not the best move by the
way
i could win some material
that's not the main focus however in
this one i've just exchanged my bad
bishop for my opponent's good bishop
and i'm trying to
play against
my opponent's dark square bishop
and eventually we get to a position
he's playing it out a bit more
eventually both rooks are exchanged
and they okay they dropped a pawn they
helped me out a little bit there of
course
but notice the decision made right
around here pawn fixed right here i
don't want to see this happen because my
pawn will be fixed on a dark square and
maybe he'll sneak around one day and
target it so i make sure to play h3
have my pawns on light squares i don't
i'm not playing with the bishop in this
position but i'm trying to play against
my opponent's bad bishop
my opponent then played g5
and it starts to look maybe a little bit
like
that ridiculous position i started this
video out with
where nearly all pawns were fixed on you
know this one rank and the bishop was
never able to see any of the squares on
the other side of the board we're really
close to that type of position and this
was just played not too long ago
now
how bad is this position for black well
not only is black down a pawn but i'd
just like to emphasize
how
the knight
and the pawn structure alone
can
prevent
the black king from entering my side of
the board i
just want to play out
a hypothetical
variation
suppose these moves were played
just throwing the king in the corner
these are not good moves by white
they're not losing moves but i just want
to emphasize
that
the knight
and just the pawn structure alone
prevents black from making any good
progress
the king cannot enter on a5
the pawns are controlling the light
squares and of course the king is not
able to ever make use of the squares
that the black pawns are on there is
good harmony in this particular case
between the knight
and pawn structure white
is playing in this position with
we we call this a good night
versus a bad bishop type position
now this is not how the game progressed
from here what i did was get my king
over towards the a file
to
control that square this is really the
only part of the board i need to control
if i really wanted to draw i would just
go back and forth with my king right
here i'm looking for more
and well the rest of the game really
isn't
of interest to us
uh kind of played out like this these
pawns end up dropping
and yeah you go on to win
the big thing here
is what decision did i make very early
on i was seeing a way to
try and exchange
at this moment right here
exchange my bad bishop
for my opponent's good bishop this is
in general a very good strategy this is
a welcome
piece exchange for white
moving on let's put another one
up here
all right
there we go
now
in this position it's white to move
you'll notice that black is up a couple
pawns
but
black has
bad harmony here
uh
black has the dark scar bishop and two
pawns they're
you know black is up two pawns here but
has uh does not have good harmony
between the bishop and structure so what
does this mean
white now has an opportunity to blockade
to stop the pawns in
in their tracks
not allow them to go forward
knight or excuse me king to e2
followed up with knight to f3 there's no
way
for black to make progress here
because the pawns are on dark squares
even though black is up two pawns this
is a drawn position
white is able to establish what we say
uh is a light square blockade and
there's no way
to
capture the knight the knight will
always have squares to go to you could
try to
take away all the squares but there's
always just too many
for the knight
however you look at it there's no way
for the bishop and king to control all
of these squares
and this will be a drawn position
because
uh black does not have good harmony
between their bishop
and pawn structure this can turn out to
be one of the downsides
to having
uh you know to to not having good
harmony between your structure
and bishop you can be up material you
could be up two pawns
maybe in some cases even more
and uh yeah we're seeing that there's a
way for white to in fact draw
this position
if we look at this position
uh slightly you know just slightly
change this one up
and work with this one here where the
pawns are a little bit further back
notice in that last example they were
really close to queening right
well
notice that the black pawns are further
back but notice
another thing and the most important
thing here is that there's good harmony
between the bishop and
structure
bishop is on light pawns are on dark
black will be able to go on to win
trying to set up some type of blockade
like this will not work the bishop is
always in a position to challenge
either piece
let's see how black will quickly
be able to make some progress here
for example
king to f5 king f7
king f4
black is advancing
keeping pawns on dark squares along the
way
king e3
the bishop can help out
and we have a nice blend of control
over the fourth rank squares
king to e2
he could
actually step up here and the very next
move
for example will be f4 keeping the pawns
on dark you never really want to end up
in summary with both your pawns on light
squares
you could at some point have a pawn on
the light and the other on dark but the
very next step you're really going to
want to make here is black
is something like f4
where you're back to having a nice blend
nice control over both colors of the
board
black will
continue in this manner making progress
and eventually promoting one of the
pawns okay
good harmony is the big thing here pawns
on dark bishop on light
that's good news for team black black
will be able to win this position
let's have a look at another
all right
let's see now
right out of the opening
how
black can lose
okay now
some of you may
be thinking
why would i ever
give up my bishop for a night
of course this is just not a good idea
but this is not
a losing move it's not a good
decision but it's not a losing move
yet
let's see a
uh
let's see what black does to lose just a
couple of moves away here
black just gave up the dark square
bishop
knight f3 black castles
after b3
you're gonna have to forgive me those of
you who are a bit more experienced this
next move that you're about to see is
going to make you cringe
e6
that move right there
to a player who has a good positional
sense
makes you cringe for me at least okay e6
that last move move six here it's
already a losing move
wow
black does not have a dark square bishop
and is placing pawns on light squares
hang on
when you have
when your remaining bishop in this case
is a light square bishop
in general
you should be placing your pawns on the
opposite color
black
squares in this
case you need to coordinate your
remaining bishop with your pawn
structure
this is already game over for black
after bishop to b2
the dark square weaknesses along this
diagonal are too great
for black
there's no saving
black in this position the knight is
struck at now twice
queen and bishop
and if he moves
mate
in one
way or even a second way
and the other option of let's say going
to g7 well hang on
here comes the g pawn trying to take
advantage of the pin black had only
stopped this for so long
with these type of moves
and in the end
after queen e5 there's going to be no
saving
the game
white will win the g pawn and eventually
crash through
the big issue here
is
not that black
gave up the dark square bishop it's true
that that was not a good idea to give up
the bishop for night here in general the
bishops are worth
a little bit more
than the knights
but
this isn't a losing move
okay it turned losing
when black decided to place pawns on the
same color square
as his remaining bishop
what should
black be doing instead
let's still run with this idea where
black gives up the bishop for knight but
let's make a very important
adjustment
okay
so
what is that adjustment exactly
let's see
bishop for night exchange still
after castles and b3
black plays d6
this is at least a step in the right
direction
uh this is a step in the direction of
let's say harmonizing
the structure and bishop
pawn on a dark square following up after
bishop to b2
we have
another pawn
being fixed on a dark square this ties
in well with the bishop some more
dark square control you're certainly not
going to get dark square bishop
controlled by your bishop you're working
with the light square bishop in this
case
after d3 we have e5 this is a good
way forward for black again
the initial decision to give up bishop
for knight was not good but at least
black is now following up well
positioning pawns on the dark squares
if play were to continue
a good
plan for white
can be to try and now break down
the pawns that are on dark squares right
try
to
mobilize let's say
this dark square bishop what i've
referred to before
you know when i'm playing a blitz game
or
you know
when i'm providing commentary while
playing
that's the x factor bishop that's uh the
unopposed bishop this is the piece that
hasn't
you know he he cannot be challenged
there's no counterpart there's no dark
square bishop that can challenge him
he's very powerful
black needs to make sure he does not
uh his vision is not extended let's say
okay so in this position
after e5
rook to e8 is a is a fine move but if
black starts to
you know give up
their strong center points well guess
where we're where we're at we're back to
square one where
this diagonal is now incredibly weakened
there's not e5 anymore so now
white is seeing not only f6 but maybe g7
and h8 the dark squares are collapsing
in this position
that's my main point you give up your
dark square bishop you better have
control over your dark squares with the
pawns
they're now responsible for controlling
the dark squares
let's continue
with
next example
here we go
this is
known as the nimzo indian defense
now
we can't yet identify
which bishops are good or bad
we might i mean because there aren't any
fixed pawns in this position just yet
but uh this is
i would say the better of the two
bishops currently
you know we have a
generally we look towards the center of
the board and those
uh you know the pawns that are in this
area of the board let's say
to uh those let's say the key pawns to
focus in on
uh not only just
not just the fixed ponds but really the
the pawns that are more focused towards
the center
those are the the more important pawns
right now we have a pawn that's on e6
that's a palm that's on a light square
he's probably the the more important
bishop let's say
and he is now
giving himself up
for the night
so what should black be doing next
ideally what color squares
should black's pawns be on
dark
need to now coordinate
harmonize the bishop and structure
d6 that's a step in that direction this
is a good way forward
b6 is another
another pawn on a dark square preparing
to develop the bishop
and another pawn advance
upon position on c5 this is a good way
to
follow up if you're giving up your dark
square bishop
black may at some point
with enough preparation even play e5 and
establish yet another
pawn in the center in this case on
a dark square okay there's good harmony
at least
between
black's remaining bishop
and pawn structure
let's have a look at another one
here we go
and these uh next handful of examples
are very basic i just want to give you a
feel for how
one can go about deploying
uh
a bad bishop
outside of
your pawn chain
see what i mean by this
this uh has a name here this is known as
the london system
playing on the white end here
a london system starting out with d4
and in fact after these first moves
right d4 d5 we already have an instance
of fixed pawns we can already
identify good and bad bishops
bad bishop
good bishop
on black end
on the black end
bad bishop
good bishop
we look to once more
the fixed pawns in order to identify
these
bishops as either good or bad
what white is doing next bishop f4 is
establishing the bishop
outside of
the pawn chain it's in a position where
it at least observes
uh
black's side of the board
i've sometime i've i have sometimes uh
referred to this bishop as the
expendable
bishop
you know if he is captured
by let's say a knight or the dark square
bishop well if he's captured by the dark
square bishop that would be a a bad
bishop for good bishop exchange
but even if he is captured by a knight
it's kind of like okay you know you got
my you got my bad bishop but i still
have
uh
what would that leave me with that would
still leave me with a
a good bishop good harmony between my
structure and my remaining
bishop
so that's as far as i want to take it
with this one this is a
known as a london system d4
the bishop to f4 you're outside of your
pawn chain
you have activated your bad bishop in
other words
let's have a look at another
this one here
this is
black now
is
deploying
the bad bishop right we can identify bad
bishops and good bishops in this
position by the d4 and d5 pawns
black is now deploying their bad bishop
outside of
the pawn chain
black has activated the bad bishop this
is uh
known as the caro khan defense if you're
wondering
let's have a look at
another example
here we go
black in this position it's playing the
slav defense
d4 is met with d5 after c4 c6
knight f3 knight f6
bishop to f5 sometimes you have to be a
little bit careful deploying
uh you know it could be a little bit
difficult to let's say activate your bad
bishop playing on the black end
for example b7 is a little bit weak and
can be targeted but the main focus here
i just want to show you
how you can be activating your bad
bishop and getting it to
play a productive role and putting it in
a position so it is not stuck behind
your pawn chain
knight c3
e6
and taking out a little bit further
we're noticing now
that white is looking to hunt down
the bad bishop in this case
there's a knight for bishop exchange
white is now working with the bishop
pair
and how is the structure in remaining
bishop for black it's okay
black has still
good harmony
with structure
and remaining bishop bishop on dark
pawns ideally in the central area
are on light squares there's good
harmony here
good control over both color
squares we could see the bishop
pivoting here have good control over the
light squares the dark squares
and yeah good harmony in this position
even though there was that knight for
bishop exchange black still has that
good bishop that's the more important of
the bishops
let's have a look at another one
here we go
okay
e4 d5 this is known as the scandinavian
defense
queen is coming out early
now in this particular case we do not
have
any fixed pawns in the center but you'll
notice
bishop f5 is played prior to
e6
we would consider this guy as
okay not in the truest sense bad bishop
but
you know these are pawns that could
certainly have
gotten in his way but black did well to
do what
activate this uh light square bishop
first before
you know he's caught behind
his own pawns
for example if you're playing e6 here
what kind of a productive role is your
light square bishop going to play you're
just going to be staring at your own
pawns
now sometimes this happens in a game
where your bishop doesn't get outside of
your pawn chain and
only later on do you try to get him
activated
but
you know
first things first we want to in general
know
how exactly to activate these pieces we
want to know of course which ones are
good which ones are bad
black is
first
getting the bishop outside of the pawn
chain then playing e6 and we go from
here
black has a very solid structure we may
even see something similar
like in the last example a knight for a
bishop exchange well
that happens again that's true we don't
have any fixed pawns here but still
we would say
i would say here black has good
coordination
between
structure
and remaining bishop
central pawns
on light
we're working here with a dark square
bishop
let us continue here
another example
here we go
this is a french defense e4
followed up with e6
we call that the french defense
and this one is a little bit more
involved you'll notice at this moment
here we basically have
a couple sets of fixed pawns
this would be
uh white's
bad bishop
this would be white's good bishop
and on black's end
this is black's bad bishop
and the other guy
is the good bishop he ties in well with
these fixed pawns
just playing it out a little bit more
i want to see how you can go ahead and
activate
that light square bishop as black here
how can black
one day
free this guy so that he's no longer
just staring at the e6 pawn
we can see a little zigzag type of
maneuver
and eventually he starts to observe
the white side of the board and put
pressure
on some of the white pieces so this is a
way you need to be able to
identify which pieces are poorly
positioned
which pieces are struggling the most in
this position the knights stand well
they're in this key 16 squares of the
board
the bishop on c5 ties in well with the
central structure it's really the light
square bishop that needs to
play
a better role
it's uh said that
one poorly placed piece
in your own position and you could
really just have a poor game so you
really need to be able to identify
the poor pieces and bring them to life
we're seeing this in action right here
out of the french defense
continuing how many more basic examples
do i have i have no more
in fact what i do have as an example
next
and
this may
this may be an interesting example i
have three
examples like this
you'll notice that the initial
piece placement here is
randomized this is a a variant chest
known as fischer random
you begin a game and yeah you don't know
what kind of setup you're going to get
it's kind of a mix
of minor pieces and i must admit that
whenever i play
a variant like this whenever i play
the fisher random varian if there is one
concept that is in my mind right out of
the gates right out of the opening it is
this one right here the one that
involves good bishops and bad bishops
what i'm trying to do
is find a way
to
activate my bad bishop
trying to find a good way to coordinate
my structure with bad bishop
now
how did this game play out i'm not
going to go into any great detail here i
was playing as
white in this game this was a five
minute game played not too long ago
d4 was met with d5 and boom
already i'm saying to myself okay this
is my bad bishop
this is my good bishop for my opponent
that's the bad bishop
and the one on f8 is the good bishop
okay i can't really
you know i can't really influence these
guys anymore all i could do right now in
this case
is focus on activating my bad bishop how
do i go about doing this
all ready for move two i'm focused on
getting this guy to a good post
h3 and then
bishop to h2
at least he is now playing i found a way
to
coordinate my structure with my bishop
he is
essentially
outside of my pawn chain he is not let's
say hemmed in over here
you know and these guys are in his way
he has a clear sight
of my opponent's side of the board
i don't know how instructive the
remainder of this game will be i'll just
play it out a little bit more quickly
uh what eventually happens that's
interesting to note okay something right
there
um
yeah oh we have a
a good bishop
for bad bishop exchange this that last
exchange right there favored white just
a little bit
why well
the remaining structure the remaining
central structure ties in well with my
bishop
this isn't so bad for for black you know
there's only one pawn on a light square
in the center it's not fixed
okay white is just a tiny bit better
there's other factors of course
white is a fourth ranked pawn versus
black's third ranked pawn okay
that's not our focus in this video but
just playing it out a little bit more
eventually what happens is i
play against the light square bishop
and uh he kind of struggles
he is not allowed to exchange himself
off for any of my pieces
and i'm okay if there's this knight for
bishop exchange
that eventually happens
and yeah i'm making some progress on the
queen side okay i have a good night
established right here this bishop is
you know he's he's staring at his own
pawns
we now have a a bishop for knight
exchange and who stands well in this
environment this is a good knight versus
a
bad bishop type position it's true that
this pawn is not
a fixed pawn in the truest sense i don't
have a pawn obstructing
a pawn that is stopping this pawn from
moving but my knight certainly does a
very good job
of preventing this pawn from moving this
is a bad bishop versus good night
position
and okay that's really the the big thing
here my opponent fell for a fork and
that was that
but the big thing here is trying to find
a way
to coordinate my structure
with my bishop even in these uh type of
variants this uh fischer random game
okay
let's have a look at uh there's just two
more
uh fisher random games that i'd like to
share with you
here's
another
where
yeah let me flip the board
in this one i'm playing as black in this
game
so right from move one
i'm identifying the the bad bishops good
bishops this is my bad bishop so i'm
trying to find a way to get him
activated for supporting my center point
i don't want to give this guy up so
easily
they bring the night out and here we go
i'm activating my light square bishop
and in fact
i
look to give him up right away for the
night
damage my opponent's structure and then
what am i doing
i'm coordinating my structure with my
remaining bishop
pawns on light bishop on dark that's the
big thing to know
and just playing it out a little bit
more we're seeing a case here now it is
true that
looking at the
the center pawns here
this guy and this guy
on white's end we would consider this
bishop the bad bishop
and this guy
has the good bishop
but
this bad bishop is
of course having a great influence on
what it is i would like to do in this
position i want to get my king castled
and i need to get rid of this bishop
he's he's an active
bad bishop uh i need to exchange him off
in order for me to make some forward
progress sometimes you have to make
these
uh decisions this is one of them
i trade dark square bishops
and eventually i'm able to get castle
now it is true
i don't have my dark square bishop i'm
just playing with two knights here
but here's the big thing to note with
this position my opponent has a bishop
right i don't have any bishops my
opponent has a bishop
i better make sure that my pawns are
around to control their bishop
okay
i do have that there's uh
you know nearly all of my pawns are
around to
restrict this guy my queen
she'll she'll be the one who tries to uh
watch over
uh the dark squares in this case
i don't know how much more
i really want to go with this one yeah
this is as far as i really want to take
this example right here
okay but again right out of the gate
you could identify the good bishops bad
bishops try to activate the bad bishops
if you can
and i did just that
and put pawns on light squares ties in
well with my remaining bishop
one last example with the fisher random
here we go
what color was i playing in this game
oh i was playing as white
and this is the center structure very
quickly is defined
um
many instances of fixed pawns
yeah few instances of fixed pawns we
could identify good and bad bishops this
game is over before move 25
and the reason for this is in large part
due to
me exchanging off my bad bishop
for my opponent's good bishop
now how does that take shape let's see
eventually
right at this point here
i'm already setting my sights
on this type of bishop maneuver
i want to get my bishop
uh
outside of
this pawn chain
bishop e3
and queen a3
i'm keying in on these dark squares some
bishop d2
bishop to b4 look at this maneuver
these are all moves made with my dark
square bishop
my opponent whether he realizes it or
not
is exchanging off his good bishop for my
bad bishop then again this was a very
active bad bishop i had
that exchange comes about and now i have
very good
harmony between my remaining structure
and my bishop
this guy on the other hand is a very bad
bishop
nearly all of black's pawns
are on light squares and they're working
with a light square
bishop black has we can say very poor
dark square control black has
dark square weaknesses sometimes i get
that question how do you know if i have
light square weaknesses or dark square
bish
dark square weaknesses
uh yeah we look to the pawn structure we
also
uh identify what kind of bishop are we
working with
yeah you have a bishop that's on a light
square and all your pawns are on a light
square
you have dark square weaknesses most
likely
and i guess
just playing it out to its end we're
actually quite close
i'm able to sneak right in and
this is already a game over position but
the big point here once more
identify the the good bishops the bad
bishops
it's almost always
a good thing to
make a bad bishop for good bishop
exchange right we saw that
in action uh at this
last move here
when i captured on
f8 here i just exchanged off my bad
bishop for my opponent's
good bishop
my opponent as a result has now
dark square weaknesses that i was able
to take advantage of both my queen and
knight jumping into these dark squares
okay that's the last
of the
960 examples
let's have a look at
how we can go about trading off
a bad bishop
for a good bishop
out of uh you know back to regular chess
okay
quickly
observing the bad bishops and good
bishops we can
look to these pawns here to
define which bishops
are good or bad
this is bad this is good
this is bad on c8 this is good
see let's see what black does in this
position
this is the bad bishop keep in mind
after castles
this is a fine move
black's last move it may seem a little
bit weird right
developing the bishop to
the edge okay normally we think moving
the knight to the edges
is not so good but okay yeah there's a
clear purpose here what is what is black
doing trying to exchange off their bad
bishop for white's good bishop
that happens
and that's as far as we want to take it
the resulting structure for black is
very good good harmony between structure
and bishop
let's continue having a look at
this next example
here we go and there's just one
another take on this position
similar structure same pawn moves as in
the last example but now we have
this may strike some as a little bit odd
why is black deploying their dark square
bishop
in a position like this why is black all
of a sudden
let's say welcome to
their good bishop being exchanged off
for white's bad bishop well black has a
a a clear
idea in mind with this and what is that
exactly well
black wants to
liberate
his
bad bishop black wants to
push through with the e5 advance so the
bishop can come out
along this diagonal so
it's uh maybe a little bit weird to view
like this but black is
giving up his good bishop
for
white's bad bishop
in order to
help activate in this case
the bad bishop
after this exchange
that's as far as i want to take it
i don't know really in this position
that i really could see consider either
bishop as good or bad
there aren't any fixed pawns yes it's
true there's a central pawn here that is
on a a light square so
okay it could get in the way a little
bit
uh
you know it could get in the the
bishop's way a little bit but yeah this
is a completely
evenish position
and
yeah i just wanted to emphasize good for
bad bishop exchange in this case in
order to free up
there's a clear idea in mind
uh
with this giving up the good for a bad
bishop exchange and that is to activate
the bad bishop in this case
you should always have a a very good
reason if you are
to give up
your good bishop and black has
justification
for
this
piece exchange
so let's have a look at another one
okay
here's an example where black simply
gives up his dark square bishop
for the knight
now that's the good bishop that black
just gave up for the night
what does black get in return
well a black damaged white's queen side
structure
okay it's not uh
you know there's something that black
got
in return for giving up the good bishop
it's important that you get something in
return for that that is the the better
of the two bishops that black just gave
up
black would now have to take very good
uh very good care over
the dark squares because there is not
black now does not
have good harmony between the resulting
structure and bishop
pawns on light bishop on light
you better be really careful you do not
have good dark square control
but on the other hand
black has damaged
white's queen side pawn structure and
there are
this is tying in to tying in now with uh
video 13 from this playlist there are
holes
created
by uh making this capture black
has now saddled white with some holes on
white's
queen side of the board
c4
and c3 are an example of holes
in this position
let's have a look at another example
still out of this uh opening here but
getting it to
a good knight versus bad bishop position
here we go
so this is a french defense if you're
wondering the variation where the bishop
takes the knight here is known as the
winowar
and if we're to continue it or play it
out just a little bit more
what black can try here
is
a
bad bishop
for
good bishop
exchange
you get just that
and taking it a step further
if black can somehow manage a knight
exchange and we do have that
the resulting position here this is a
good environment
for black black is playing with a good
knight
versus a bad bishop this knight will
take up a wonderful post
in this hole on c4
a light square and no one
can challenge him the bishop will not be
able to challenge him pawns
just by the definition of it being a
whole the pawns of course cannot
challenge a knight that is on c4 black
is the preferred side here
continuing with
these examples
here we go
what do we have here here is an example
of something you should not do
here we go
what should you not do what is an
example of something you should not do
let's see
uh there aren't any fixed pawns but if
we
have a look at the bishops
on white's end
i kind of like both bishops i don't know
that we could really say
this will sometimes happen
just kind of undefined
i can't really say that either bishop is
bad here there aren't any fixed pawns
for white
there's a pawn on a dark square and a
light square who knows right they're
both they'll both be able to do
something productive that's for sure
on black's end it will have an easier
time defining
which one is uh worse off you know this
bishop here is the good bishop
it's really the one on c8 who is bad
okay so here's something you would not
want to do as an example
after a bishop to d7
don't you dare
take that bishop that is a piece of
garbage that was just captured right
there on d7 that is a bad bishop what's
more that's a bad bishop behind a pawn
chain
that is a bad bishop behind a pawn chain
that does not even serve
any useful purpose
okay
it's a completely dead piece
this is something you know if you just
have it in your mind that oh knights are
worth or excuse me bishops are worth
more than
knights well here's my opportunity to
take the bishop no way
no way this night is
far more valuable
than this guy on d7 okay this is
something you should not
be doing
let's have a look at another one
here we go
a french defense
okay you ready for this one
where are all the chess players who like
giving checks raise your hand
you love giving checks right bishop to
b4
hang on though that's your good bishop
that's coming out there to give a check
are you sure you want to do this
watch what happens bishop d2
bishop takes bishop thank you so much
black
thank you so much you just gave up your
good bishop for my bad bishop
now
watch what happens
okay
this guy's the bad bishop
got a good bishop ties in well with our
structure good harmony for white
not so much for black
and the queens come off the board
this guy is not going to be able to
exchange himself off or anyone
there are not
these are not the most accurate moves
being played here of course
but just to illustrate
we have another case here
where it is a very good knight
versus
a really bad bishop
okay bishop that is obstructed by his
own pawns behind his own pawn structure
and this knight is going to camp out
a couple very good options here for
the white knight just showing a position
like this very quickly to
someone with
you know this type of understanding this
uh
someone who has an understanding of this
concept
you know they're quickly able to
identify oh i'm definitely taking white
here look at look at this knight look at
this terrible bishop
this is what are we doing we're
analyzing this we're making assessment
of this position
you should prefer
team white uh big time in this position
okay
and what made this possible
maybe you're a player who would be
really excited
maybe i i i i think in some players
minds that they get excited that you
know you're giving check to your
opponent
i'm almost like you're um
maybe
maybe i'm gonna win check it's close to
checkmate i don't know exactly the
thought process that goes into it but
this is such a bad decision to
deploy
your good bishop
just to give check
and
now what just happened
you just gave up
your good bishop for your opponent's bad
bishop
okay
something to
shy away from
black should not be playing a move like
bishop to b4
now things are going to
start to get
a little bit more involved here
let's bring up another one
and this is
this is a game i played not all the
games are
that i'm showing here are games that i
played with this is another one i played
playing as white
this is a one minute game
so let's see
at what point can i
kind of identify good or bad bishops
right around this point i'm not really
seeing
you know which
i'm not really identifying either my
bishops as good or bad
okay maybe i'm tending more towards my
dark square bishop as being bad but as
it is right now there is not yet any
pawns fixed in the center
takes takes d5 okay after d5 e5 boom
right here
now i'm saying to myself okay that's my
bad bishop this is my good bishop i'd
really like to exchange him him off
let's see what happens
get my knight out
i'm now keying in on this hole here on
c5 okay let's get on with it bishop g5
what does my opponent do
bishop to e7 thank you so much
thank you so much
that's your good bishop this is my bad
bishop
yes let's do it
now
i have good harmony between my remaining
structure and my bishop what happens
next i take out the knight i play h4
and now i have complete control over
this position
control over the dark squares
and
this bishop will never even see a single
square on my side of the board
i think yeah what was it the first
example i showed in this video
the one that i said yeah you're probably
thinking it's ridiculous
it's kind of like
you know we have that going on here for
black
a full rank of pawns on light squares
this bishop he's never going to see any
square on my side of the board
how did play continue well it was so bad
black felt the need
to give up
the exchange as otherwise this knight is
going to be super glued into g5 and
there's going to be nothing you could do
on the king side and you could already
do nothing on the queen side because of
the control over the c5 square the c5
hole
the big problem here for team black is
that they're playing with the tall pawn
on b7 yes this is a tall pawn on b7
okay he's a really bad
bishop
just playing it out a little bit more to
show
eventually black isn't at a point where
you could do nothing but simply shuffle
okay
clearly these moves here are not
productive i know it's just a bullet
game
things were to continue the knight
returns the pawn pushes eventually i
have a passed pawn
white's going to be able to make
progress the big issue here
the big issue here
is
well maybe even before this point but
the big issue is this moment here
bishop e7
that's my bad bishop
exchange for your good bishop and what
this could ultimately translate into
are situations like this where
you're left with a really bad bishop
that is not harmonized with your
structure
really bad bishop stuck behind
your your pawn chain in this case
okay
let's have a look at another one
here we go
okay let's see what we get here
okay this i think will be a bit more
instructive now as as i mentioned i'm
trying to present these in a
these examples in a progressive way
so here we go
after e5
takes takes already this moment right
here five moves in
good bishop's bad bishops
we should have that down by now
let's see what white does
bishop to g5
how many of you playing as white right
now might play a move
like bishop to g5 now let me just say
here
this isn't a bad move or excuse me this
isn't a losing move in any way but is
this really a good idea is this a good
way to deploy your bishop are you
excited
about oh
i'm now pinning my opponent's knight to
the queen
let me tell you how
uh you know
let me just say that that is
far from an
inconvenience for black here
you know why
bishop e7
black just
developed
broke the pin
and what's more
black is now in a position we're just a
moment away here
we're just a moment away
from having a bad bishop
for good bishop exchange
as white do you really want that to
happen
well it does happen in this game
playing it out a little bit more
let's see what happens
the knight moves
and boom we have it right there
good bishop for bad bishop exchange
does white have good harmony
between structure and bishop
no
let's also consider something else in
this position looking at the center of
the board let's look at the four center
squares these guys here any holes for
white
oh yeah this guy here on d4 that's a
dark square
white is going to find it very difficult
to control the d4 square black could now
devise a plan to eliminate any piece
that could try to control the d4 square
okay
we already know this guy and e4
won't be able to do it
it's only the knights that will be able
to let's say shoo away
a
a minor piece that sits on the d4 square
but if black now follows up and makes
the correct kind of
peace exchanges
right
there's no way the knight's gonna take
the the bishop on e2
no way
a knight exchange
happens and
this is uh you know this is a bishop
that ties in well with
a black structure but what black's doing
now is eliminating the last piece that
could watch over the d4 square and what
do we have
another instance of a good knight versus
bad bishop position
after knight to e6 this is as far as i
want to go
this environment is fantastic for team
black
the knight will camp out on d4 and make
these rooks that are currently
controlling the only open file
in the game the d file they will be shut
down
the knight will drop into d4 and be an
animal
he's going to be a beast on d4
okay he he sits now
in a hole in the white position now this
was made possible
be
you know how did this come about because
of this early decision right here to
even play
bishop to g5
that's your good bishop take better care
of him
bishop e7 eventually these guys got
exchanged
and black found a way to play against
the bishop on e2
okay
let's have a look at another one
okay
here we go
now here's something a little bit
counter-intuitive
this opening is a
sicilian opening
okay after this move here we could
identify good bishops bad bishops
and
you know looking at that last example
you may think this next move
well isn't this kind of similar
you're pinning the knight to the queen
there's another factor a very important
factor
to think about in this position you
notice that black has
a weakness on d5 and so
an idea can be to try and eliminate
pieces that control d5 and then one day
try to occupy d5 this is something i
touched on
in video 13 which is really
if you haven't seen that video it's a
very important video
um
yeah
discussing chess holes
okay there's this idea to give up the
good bishop
for the night just to
get rid of defenders of the weak point
on d5
but here's another thing
after bishop to e7
here is something you know someone
playing as black now with this
understanding of good bishops and bad
bishops
may
make the following move
knight to d7
and at first glance um what can we say
knight to d7 is
welcoming
a
bad bishop
for good bishop exchange
is this a good idea though
it's not in this particular case
because
the d6 pun
is
vulnerable
after rook after d1 there is not a good
way
for black to defend the d6 pawn
now i know this was just a like two
moves deep okay
you know of course i'm not going to
retreat my knight to d7
some of you could maybe have calculated
this knight d7
uh after bishop takes queen takes yeah i
saw that after rook to d1 my palm will
be attacked twice and i couldn't defend
it for a second time of course i'm not
going to do that
um
this is
this is true you should not you should
not be doing this as is black playing
knight to d7 even though
we have this uh you know bad bishop for
good bishop exchange black is going to
now drop a pawn this is not a good idea
for black what we're observing here
this is the main point
what we're observing here is that
sometimes
the bad bishop
can
be very important or in this case the
bad bishop is
uh
serving a very useful role
there's a phrase out there that that
runs uh
how does it go bad bishops
sometimes
uh support
important pawns or some something
something to that uh something to that
effect
bad bishops protect important pawns okay
this is an important pawn
okay this is the
most efficient defender of d6 keep in
mind that this is a backward pawn
and you know he is likely to be struck
at by many major pieces
and yeah without him
we could very easily see that the the
d-pawn will fall and in fact uh that's
what's going to happen on the very next
move
okay so maybe something a little bit
counter-intuitive there we can't just
always be fixated on okay let me just
get rid of my bad bishop for my
opponent's good bishop and everything is
going to be
you know
fantastic no we're seeing uh
we have to look a little bit deeper
sometimes is this a bad bishop that has
a a useful role
yes in this case he's he's very
important to hang on to
otherwise he may be
playing without a pawn
okay
let's put another one up there
here we go
another
sicilian
and what more
to offer with this one let's get to
this key position yes
here we go
bishop to g5
okay
i like this example a lot
what is white doing with this last move
white is offering
a bad bishop for good bishop exchange
how should you reply to this as black
this is very important what would you do
here
what you should not do is capture the
bishop
a better move
okay this isn't a losing or anything but
a better decision
in this position is to say
okay i have a weakness on d5
okay
if we're going to have a light square
bishop exchange i would like you to at
least help me out a little bit i would
like you to repair the the one
big weakness the hole in my position on
d5
you know it's a good move here for black
bishop to e6
it is true
that white can capture
the bishop and have this
bad bishop for good bishop exchange
and
this would not be a case of you know
black having doubled pawns that are bad
in any way
this is an extremely important pawn on
e6 all of a sudden one who
now
repairs
a uh weakness in black's camp
bishop e6 is a fantastic reply to an
offer of a
bad bishop for good bishop exchange in
this case
black is saying yeah okay we could have
that but at least you're gonna help me
out a little bit
bishop e6 pawn takes
uh on e6 and you know the knight has to
find a new home all of a sudden
black has a little bit more
uh control over
light squares and dark squares
okay you wouldn't get that
if let's say black just captured on g4
now this knight is a really strong piece
something like this happened okay this
is
not a good idea but notice how a knight
on d5 there's no one who's going to get
rid of him
and
this would be another case of a very
strong knight
versus a um a bad bishop
pawns on dark bishop on dark
okay
bishop e6 a little bit more of an
advanced uh
move here white tries to get rid of the
the bad bishop for the good bishop and
black says okay hang on help me out just
a little bit if that is to happen bishop
e6 is a good move a good reply to bishop
g4 in this case
okay here is
another
example i this is a game i played and
this one did not turn out well for me
some of you may
this may be
a bit more fresh in some of your
yeah in the minds of many of you
uh watching this right now this is a
game i played not so long ago
playing as black and a very important
middle game decision came about
in this one and i did not i did not make
a good
assessment of this middle game position
and i would like to share with you uh
what i could have done better
first what did i do playing is black now
uh we can let me back up for a moment
this is my next move but okay this
position right here first off
let's take some notes here uh note
the pawns that are fixed here
let me just highlight from my
perspective first
these guys here
dark square pawn chain in the center
that's my bad bishop
i should be looking to get rid of my bad
bishop this is my good bishop
he ties in well with my structure
on white side
they have good coordination good harmony
between structure and bishop they're
cool there
i play f5 now this is not a uh not the
the best idea the computer is suggesting
that i just
give up my bishop for the night that is
one option
but even after this
this f5 move
this is where i made a really big
mistake
okay i
played bishop takes f5 and my opponent
replied very well
okay there's now a chain reaction of
captures here this is my good bishop
keep in mind
my opponent
takes out my good bishop
and then takes out my knight and i knew
that this would happen
i knew that i would be left
with a bishop that did not tie in well
with my central structure
but i did not uh assess things properly
the the reason why i went in for
something like this is because i thought
that
i was let's say
giving some weight
to
me now having a past pawn
the d-pawn is now passed but
as the game played out i was never
really able to even move a single step
with this pass pawn it was almost like
it didn't even cause an inconvenience
to white whatsoever my having this past
pawn
and eventually
uh white was able to make progress
over here getting a passed pawn
and yeah my bishop turned out to be a
really really bad piece
my opponent took advantage of this very
well and i ended up i think resigning
right around here
or not okay i got mated okay but the big
thing here was the decision i made the
middle game decision i made i did not
make a good choice with my minor pieces
what could i have done better
at this point at least
knight takes f5 would have been better
knight takes f5 bishop takes f5
i'm playing with the bishop pair i still
have my good bishop around to maybe
challenge the knight he can return to e6
this would have been a better decision
but again as it played out
i took with my good bishop first
thinking that there would be some
value in having a past pawn now that was
a poor assessment and my my opponent
followed up very well and i was never
able to
you know
show that my bishop was
good in any way
yeah okay this is a bad bishop i should
refrain from using that term
too frequently yeah this is a this is a
bad bishop i do not have good harmony
between my structure and my bishop my
opponent
punished me because of that
really really strong knight on d5
good knight versus bad bishop position
and yeah
as you saw i ended up getting made it
i do not have too many
more examples
okay here we go
let's see what we have here oh
this is just a quick example to show
um
essential structure
fixed pawns this is the bad bishop
this is white's bad bishop
but they're both very active and so
sometimes
this will happen in a game where
you know you shouldn't be so
hesitant to
exchange your
uh good bishop for your opponent's bad
bishop like right now black's last move
is bishop to e6 sometimes the
the bad bishop can be so actively placed
that you know you kind of have to
neutralize it and that's exactly what we
have going on here this is a really
strong diagonal
this is a bishop that this is a bad
bishop that is
outside of white's
central pawn structure
black is doing what with bishop to e6
trying to neutralize it we have
it's true a bad bishop for a good bishop
exchange
and
white
you know this is a strong bishop bearing
down at the white king position
white here is welcome to a
a bad bishop for a good bishop exchange
sometimes that that could that could
happen
you know i just want to show an example
where the the bad bishops can be so
actively placed that uh
yeah you kind of have to try to get rid
of them
okay
and yeah how many more examples about
seven more a couple
a couple games to close
in this one
here's an example where
you know sometimes it's just difficult
to define
which bishops are good or bad this is a
case of a quadruple
fianchetto
notice there aren't any uh
there isn't any great definition in the
center
there isn't uh
the pawn structure is not really defined
no fixed pawns
and
[Music]
yeah i just want to show you a case
where you know it's not always going to
be
you know you're not always going to be
able to say oh this is my bad bishop
this is my good bishop here's an example
where i i don't really know i don't
really see that factoring in so much in
this position type that's really my main
point here
could very well see uh
you know all bishops simply being
exchanged for each other
no
no defined structure in the center with
that one
let's have a look at another one
here we go
okay
we have some fixed pawns and okay
something is defined here so
uh
bad bishop
um it's tough for me
i could say that this is a bad bishop
for team black this is uh the good
bishop
for white
okay i mean there's just one pawn here
but i would be really hesitant to just
say oh this is a bad bishop
you have to i mean there's going to be
other things you have to factor in but
in and this is an example uh this is a
this position is
um
when you have a bishop fee and kettled
like this he is
you know when you have a bishop being
cut out next to your king
he will often have a very important role
earlier i was talking about a bishop on
e7 having an important role of defending
the pawn on d6 sometimes your bishop can
be an
extremely important defender
of your king position
without that bishop around your king may
be vulnerable
let's see how this one plays out just a
little bit
notice there is a hole on the d5 square
white is focusing
the attention on d5
taking out
pieces that can control
d5 white is devising a plan here where
try to play against this bishop the
the bad bishop
knights exchanged
light square bishops exchange here's
just another quick way
to illustrate a good night
versus a bad bishop position
okay but this one
not uh is super clear at least on the
white end for me to say
okay yeah this is the good bishop or
this is the bad bishop sometimes it
could be a little bit tricky
and as this one played out strong knight
versus a bad bishop type position
uh
let's have a look at another one
here we go
e4 c5 in this one
okay a sicilian
and we have both sides castling
on the king side
and yeah this is another one that's
maybe a little bit tricky for me to
say which one is good or bad for black
you know there isn't a
a great defined structure in the center
uh for white you know it's it's this guy
here who's
restricted more so than anything right
this would be let's say the bad bishop
and this would be the good bishop
um
so
as a follow-up we have knight to d7
offering a dark square bishop exchange
this
this is uh
desirable
for black
one thing you do have to watch out for
is
you know you are exchanging off now
an important defender sometimes of your
king position
you know
uh without your bishop around for
example the the square h6
um
may you know your opponent may be able
to take advantage of the square h6 and
maybe you could get checkmated in this
case we have what both sides
are castled on the opposite or excuse me
on the same side of the board dark
square bishops
uh get exchanged in this one
after let's say bishop takes
bishop king takes bishop
and let's say b3
you know there isn't going to be any
attack here
black has
a couple pawns in the center dark
squares bishop on light
good harmony
and okay you could try to play against
the light square bishop playing as black
here you could try to play against the
light square bishop the main point with
this example is that it is okay
for black to make a move like knight to
d7 it is okay for black to welcome
in this case
a dark square bishop exchange
compare this however with our next
example
and we are now
just winding down with these last few
notice the one key difference in this
example
we have now a case of opposite sides
castle and
it may appear that you know this is
white's good bishop right
looking at the structure but there are
other pieces of criteria to factor in
the big one here
is again uh kings castled on opposite
sides of the board and these position
types
you're trying to attack one another's
king
that said
this bishop will be an extremely he is
in fact the number one
defender of the black king position the
most important defender
of black's king position
so with this in mind you know if you're
playing as
as white and you're only familiar with
good and bad bishops maybe you wouldn't
go in for
a move like bishop to h6
um but this is in fact a good idea okay
white is trying to eliminate
uh a very important defender in this
case of black's kingside position
and
go for checkmate and that's basically
what's going to happen
to team black very soon okay they're
eliminating the knight that is the only
defender of h7 and then crashing through
here some of you of course watching this
now are i'm sure familiar with the name
of this this is a sicilian dragon
yugoslav attack
things are different there are other
pieces of criteria
to factor in of course
beyond just looking at pawn structure
and the bishops and you know putting the
pawns on this color tied in with the
bishop of the opposite color etc that
kind of stuff
the big piece of criteria to look into
with this one
opposite sides castling
okay
that's a that's a big deal this is uh
this is again a good idea
for white to go in for
bishop to h6 in this case eliminating a
key kingside defender
carrying on
just three more examples and then two
games as a close
okay
what kind of an example is this well
this is another one where
it's a little bit tricky for me to
identify the good bishops and the bad
bishops and let me say why
this is where we're at just to sing upon
exchanged and really the best thing that
i could do right now is just share
everything
uh well
share as much as i can
about this position type
i just want to take you through my train
of thought here with how i maybe try to
break down this position where
it's clearly
um
well
i should refrain from saying clearly
it's difficult
to maybe come right out and say
that's the good bishop that's the bad
bishop because
look at the fixed pawns
okay so now we have all of a sudden a
blend
right we have a case where
looking at white's end first let's take
it step by step white has a pawn fixed
on a light square white also has a pawn
fixing on dark square so
who knows
which bishop's good or bad right
uh and looking at the black fixed pawns
we have a pawn fixed on a dark square
and a pawn that's fixed in a light
square so who knows
which one is the good bishop which one's
the bad bishop right
um
there are other pieces just like in the
last example i was drawing some
attention to opposite sides castling and
there being other pieces of criteria to
look into
in order to
properly
assess a chest position
a key factor in this position type
is this guy here this captures my
attention a great deal this is a past
pawn this is a connected pass pawn this
is a pawn
that
black should make certain
does not get the opportunity to move
forward
now
a good idea
for black
would be to play
knight to d8 what is black looking to do
here
blockade the past pawn this is the very
first thing that i looked into
okay
i would like to have a knight there to
blockade the pawn now this is
what i'm sharing right about now is
going beyond the scope of what i really
intended in this video
but i imagine those of you
looking at the the recording time right
here
i don't i imagine those of you that are
with me this long
wouldn't object to me
sharing stuff that is beyond the
the scope of this video or beyond what
my main focus is in this video
um
imagine you're really here looking to
learn if you've been with me for this
long hats off to you i've said it in a
previous video just uh just to the right
i put it up as a text on the right you
have a lot of patience if you're still
with me so i'm just saying that verbally
to you hats off to you if you're still
with me big thumbs up for you you have a
lot of patience and that's uh
yeah that's a very good attribute let's
just say to have
as a chess player especially if you're
trying to develop your strategic
understanding of the game this takes
work
so
again hats off to you if you're still
listening to these very words you have a
lot of patience and yeah that's uh
that's awesome
okay but anyhow this knight d8 move the
idea here
is to blockade this past pawn
he wants to sit on e6 the knight
is uh generally known as one of the most
efficient block haters
in the game okay not only because he
let me just put another move on the
board it's kind of like a passing move
not only because he stops this pawn from
advancing but because he is not passive
he is also aggressive he is exerting
pressure
on the supporter
of this uh
uh of this connected past pawn
so he's not strictly defensive he's
throwing some strikes here he's stopping
the pawn from moving he's throwing
punches great now with that said
if we were to try
at least to identify which bishops are
good or bad
i would have to say
that
well
what
type of bishop exchange am i welcome to
as black maybe i should just be looking
from black's perspective
as black here i would be welcome to a
light square bishop bishop exchange and
the reason i think this
is because
what i do not want to have happen is
this pawn to advance
and one way that white can try
one day at least
to get this pawn advancing
is just is to take over control of that
blockade square
now which of the two white bit which of
the two bishops on white's end will be
able to support this type of advance
it'd be the light square bishop
with that in mind i'm okay with a light
square bishop exchange
excuse me i'm okay with the light square
bishop exchange
uh as black i would try to play against
the dark square
a white dark square bishop
in this case now i know this is a little
bit more sophisticated
uh but i i i i wanted to
i wanted to show you that it can of
course
uh
get uh a bit more complicated and you
probably hear
in my explanation here
uh it's it's a bit involved this is a
complicated game but i'm still
trying to offer some insight as to how
we could still even in this position
type where it's just a single pawn
exchange how we could still try to maybe
break down
uh this position and you know accurately
assess these positions and try to
determine
uh what what peace exchanges are we may
be okay with or not okay with
okay
um is that all i wanted to add with that
one
i think so
yeah let's go on to just these last
two examples and then two uh quick games
as they close one of them is mine and
another one is
um
yeah one of them is mine from
uh 2004 a tournament game and the other
one is a game
from
uh bobby fisher
fisher petrossian
so
the quick idea now this one isn't nearly
as
involved as the that last example
uh yeah let me just point a couple
things out what's happening here okay
black no longer has a dark square bishop
and is now doing well
to
position some pawns on dark squares
and this is as far as i want to take
this example after d5
now
you'll notice i've
you know
pointed out
your remaining bishop
central pawns
you know
have some good harmony pawns on dark
bishop on light everything's great
if we look from white's perspective
uh white is playing with the bishop hair
right
and
what color squares should they be on
when you still have two bishops
right let's just pretend that these two
knights are no longer there and what we
really have is
a bishop
a two bishops versus a knight and bishop
position right
uh when you have two bishops and your
opponent has a knight in bishop
what color squares should your pawns be
on then
is there a way that we could determine
that even though we're still working
with two bishops
now i don't know how
how much of a guide
this will be for you but
i'm going to share how i reason
my way through these position types
where it's not it's not as simplified
right we're not working with
a a position type where
okay i only have one minor piece and you
have one one minor piece now it's a
little bit more involved here
in these position types this is what i
say to myself
where is my x factor bishop
my dark square bishop my unopposed
bishop
in this case white's unopposed bishop is
the dark square bishop
there is no counterpart
right black does not have a dark square
bishop
so as white i'm saying to myself
this is my x factor bishop
that's
the bishop i want to coordinate with my
structure
okay
what is
um
well i'll just share this is some
train of thought that i have
what is probable
is a light square bishop exchange i can
see that happening in this position
somehow or another i could see a light
square bishop exchange that is not
far-fetched
okay and when that happens
what would i like to have
i would like to have my pawns positioned
on light
and
that's going to tie in well
with my remaining bishop as a result
so that's just a a quick little tip when
you're working with
you know
two bishops versus a bishop at night or
well as it is right now
right two bishops and a knight
versus two knights and a bishop
where's that x-factor bishop
let me coordinate my pawn structure with
that x factor bishop just in the event
that there's a light square bishop
exchange
at least i'll have good harmony
between my structure and my remaining
bishop
okay
i don't know how helpful that was for
you but
for what it's worth that's that's the
train of thought that's what i use to
help guide my own play
and one last one before we get to
these two games as a close
still touching on this uh
idea where one side has the bishop pair
so in that last example
there were pawns fixed on light squares
notice how
as white i would really be trying to
let's say establish pawns on
light squares
right this is my x factor bishop
in the game if you're playing a move
like e3
maybe a better idea
would be to play c4 and then establish
upon
on e4 on a light square
this isn't
a losing move in any way but you know we
could see something like this happening
a light square bishop exchange and
what results okay
[Music]
a bad bishop
he's stuck inside the pawn chain it's
not
you know it's not losing but
black has good light square control and
white has to fight pretty hard to try
and uh maybe establish a pawn on e4 now
okay
just a couple quick quick uh tips there
when it's a bit more complicated like
this
bishop pair situations where's the x
factor bishop
let me coordinate my structure with that
x factor bishop
that unopposed bishop
okay
finally
we are at the very end
uh last two games let me show you first
a game that i played
as black
in 2004 so just giving you some
quick insight here
this was uh
actually played at the world open
philadelphia pa
i was playing as black
i was around 22
50 uscf
and my opponent was
nearly 2300. i'm playing the carol khan
i just gave up my
bad bishop for a night and what am i
doing i'm coordinating my resulting
bishop with my structure
and this game is basically even right to
the very end
we'll see what the result is soon enough
my opponent is playing with the bishop
pair
it's tough to say which one is even the
better bishop in this case which one is
the good bishop
there's no fixed pawns
okay if there is a better bishop i would
have to
lean towards the the light square bishop
in this case but they're both
they're both fine and of course i kind
of chuckled when i uh
refreshed my memory on this game i was
really quick to offer a queen exchange
back then
still am today
anyhow
what ends up happening in this game that
is worth noting
let me get to it
bishop takes knight okay so when that
bishop takes
bishop takes knight move happened now
what do we have that was the that was
what the better bishop right
so now we have a case of
i have a good bishop my opponent has a
bad bishop
right maybe these guys could be
vulnerable to my bishop one day
so i think i'm not 100 sure on this but
i think i was feeling uh
like okay maybe i have something in this
game but we'll see how
things change a little bit and in fact
right around here this is an important
moment
now this is a deeper idea
or a deeper train of thought here but
let me let me carry on with it
uh i played on this at this moment h5
and my fear or what i wanted to uh
my
the idea that i had behind h5 was to
make certain that one of my pawns did
not get fixed
on a dark square
if in this position i said well my king
needs to it's the end game my king needs
to play an important role let me move
him towards the center
an issue i saw with that is that my
opponent can play first g4
and let's say i continue to go towards
the center note i cannot move my pawn to
g6 and try to play h5 because my my pawn
would fall but let's just say i
continued towards the center now my
opponent can play h4
and finally h5 and maybe one day
this bishop somehow or another
can
put some pressure on my pawns that are
fixed on the
dark squares
this is something i wanted to avoid
so therefore i played h5 and there's
going to be now still a downside
with playing h5 as we will soon see
uh my opponent plays
g4 here and something is happening
a new side of the board is opening up
something i would really
i really don't want to have happen one
rook is exchanged something i do want to
have happen here
is a rook exchange
okay
i can't manage that though
um
the main point i wanted to
share in this video just
take it in
taking it out to the very end
i think we go as far as move 40. notice
i am extremely
uh passive with my rook
i have
the better bishop
right the the one who ties in better
with my uh
my bishop ties in well with my structure
their bishop not so much
on the other hand look at my rook versus
their rook there's more
there's another key
piece of criteria to look into
uh
my rook is really passive
now i wanted to share this game with you
because
what would be a desirable exchange in
these in this position type
if i could somehow manage to exchange
rooks
i would be the one who is
having an advantage there's there's like
no way
uh i'm going to lose this as black if
the rooks are off
uh but what the rooks on my opponent has
pressure on me uh we agreed to a draw at
this point there really wasn't a
a way to
make progress here i'm extremely passive
but uh
you know some position types can be like
this where
you know you have the better bishop
and you would really like it to be
you would really like it to be where
that's the only piece on the board it's
just the bishops but no there's another
piece that's
in the mix here you have a rook that
could put pressure on your pawns and
we're seeing a case here where my
uh my rook is just all of a sudden
extremely passive
and you know this will provide some
insight you know
uh
peace exchanges what are you welcome to
black if there was the if there was
somehow the offer of a
uh rook exchange white
should be saying no
no way i don't want to exchange rooks
because then you're the only one that
could somehow win putting pressure on my
pawns with your better bishop
and
as black
i'm hoping
you know for a rook exchange somehow or
some way that i could force
a rook exchange
having the rooks off
uh in this position black is better
with the rooks on
white is probably the better side white
is the one who
is in a better position here
as this one turned out it
ended up as a draw
okay
last game
and
the reason why i want to emphasize this
game here which is between fisher
bobby fisher playing on the white end
and tigran petrossian
game from
1971
the uh
game seven the candidates
match
there was a move played in this game by
fischer
and it is
one of the most talked about moves in
chess
so what move did fisher play
that was the most uh or one of the most
at least
talked about moves in chess you ready
for it
that one right there
yep
that move knight takes bishop now
there aren't any fixed pawns here well
in a way there are some pawns that are
on light squares
you'll know
and so this bishop
isn't really the greatest piece in the
world
compare this with a knight that stands
very well on c5 right he's in a hole
he's on a dark square difficult to chase
away
all right only the knight could try to
maybe uh chase him away no pawns this is
a whole
and so the decision
to play knight takes bishop
[Music]
you know got a lot of people talking
why in the world would you give up the
knife for bishop well this is a really
um
it's a it's a deeper idea
you know i showed an example earlier
where there was the
you know you gave up uh
you had the the bad bishop for good
bishop exchange or no that wasn't the
example
it was one where i said don't take
uh the knight was on e5 and i said don't
you dare take that bishop i think i
called it a piece of garbage
i said don't take the bishop
uh it was inside the pawn chain it was
inactive it was without a purpose well
fischer saw the deeper idea here and
he noted that really the the key to
activating the rooks the the way to
enter this position there's a clear
purpose with giving up this strong night
for this let's say bad bishop
the rooks would now become
active white would white will now have
inroads
into the black position so
the the big thing here is i wanted to
show that there of course will be
exceptions
uh you know to this this concept that
i'm
trying to
uh
share with you there's going to be
exceptions this is a a deeper idea we're
having a
a night for
a bishop exchange a really strong night
for not so good bishop but
this is helping white
to activate
his other pieces sometimes it can happen
like this
and
actually this game is already over
as early before it even hits move 35
this is in fact
the final move here so getting rid of
that bishop who was uh
uh
who would have
given white difficulty to activate
yeah yeah
black
had a light square bishop
that
would
limit
white's rooks right the white rooks
would not be able to enter the black
position so easily if black still had
the bishop around
fischer took out the bishop the rooks
were able to sweep in
we see it right now two rooks
on the seventh rank if play was to
continue
i don't know playing a move like knight
to d5 you could just take the knight
and eventually how are you stopping this
idea of checkmate with rook to aha
the big idea here with this last final
example this last game here
is
uh you know there's going to be
exceptions but the big thing here is
that we need to know first what is the
general principle saying
you know how should we be coordinating
our pawns with our bishops what kind of
peace exchanges are we welcome to those
minor piece exchanges uh so forth and so
on
um i think that's all i wanted to share
this is
yeah longest video for sure
in this uh playlist if you're still here
big thumbs up to you you have a lot of
patience and that's a fantastic let me
say that is a fantastic attribute to
have
as a player who is i i assume
if you're still with me you're one who
is really looking to improve your your
play and i hope as usual
a video such as this is uh useful
to your own game
and i will catch you
uh in video 24 feel free as usual to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below
and i will catch you soon that is all
for now
take care bye
you